Okay, let's discuss the solution for our flushes,
stalls and forwarding quiz. We have this five stage
pipeline. We said already that for control dependencies,
we have to use flushes. We have fetched the
wrong instructions. Delaying them or trying to fix
the values they read is not going to help us.
So here we have to flush, and we
don't stall or forward. For this state of dependence,
at the time when the load is reading the R1 here, the multiply is producing the
result here. The multiply has the result at the end of that cycle, and the load
will need to compute the address at the beginning of the next cycle. So here, we
can forward the value of R1 from the multiply to load, and don't have to stall.
Again, we don't want to use flashes here. The final question is whether
the load's result of R1, which needs to be fed to the add here, can
be forwarded, or do we have to stall? When the add
is reading R1 here, the load is here
computing the address. It still has not accessed memory.
In the next cycle the add is computing using
the wrong value for one, while the load is
still loading memory. So the load, only at the
end of this cycle, has the proper value for one.
Whereas the ADD, at the end of that cycle,
has already computed the wrong result. So in this case,
we have to stall. Interesting enough, we will actually,
after that one stall cycle, forward to avoid stalling more.
So we here, we have to have a stall, and
we can after the stall, do forwarding or just stall more.
But this is one of those situations where forwarding can
not help you. You have to stall for a data dependence.